[Music]
open a new window
so that we can always see that one and
just make it this big right
yes we're talking about will and the
uh and the and the timer
on our podcast um
now i can't even watch it he's going on
google now i can't even it's so hard
well now we're on the set now that we're
on the 70s we started
they did send in a whale google song did
you download it
[Music]
[Music]
no he's not yeah i mean if that's to
quote myself
in three months you hate to do it so
early uh
but i i hardly think will is on google
and looks at himself and goes you know
what this is me doing my best
because it's not it's not great well
now that's not about well well we're
done talking to you goodbye
um you're done you're on probation for
the rest of the rest of the podcast
um bianca just before we get into
official business let's just say
hello to each other we have a new uh for
the watchers we have new
arm things for the microphones which
pretty professional get it we get a
little more professional every week
every week i got some curtains for the
light to control the lighting a little
more it's a pretty big deal
what's up right now manga um how are you
good yes what did you i got into some
[ __ ]
this week oh do tell dick in my pocket
all right
so i got you know sometimes this is like
a crazy person something a crazy person
would do and
and like a narcissist which i wish i
were actually more of a narcissist but
i'm just selfish i'm hoping to make the
leap into the big leagues of narcissism
um i got a dash cam
ooh cool uh out
the front window and then i was supposed
to get one into the
into the cab of the car so i can say
funny [ __ ]
and just cut it up and put it on
instagram and youtube
it's literally just so i can say funny
[ __ ] when i say funny [ __ ] when i drive
and i'm like man there should be a
record of this
is it like it records like it records
yes you can go back it records 10 hours
at a time or something oh cool
so but they put in a rever uh they
didn't do into the cab they
did put it into the back of the car was
like
no dog i already have that they were
probably like
he's not driving for uber so he doesn't
need this
no you would think um they didn't know
i'm trying to make the leap
um so i'm like what the [ __ ] am i
so i'm like you know of course talking
to the guys like what's going on
uh i'm like i'm never gonna need this
within i'm not kidding i get in the car
and within 15 seconds a woman comes
behind the car and vomits
not on the car whoa but just on camera
worth it now here's it legally i didn't
bring it
legally we can do it i don't know
if you can just show video of someone
puking
like i couldn't put it on youtube i
don't think i could put it on youtube
can how much of her face can you see
i didn't even watch the video because i
was so convinced
uh that i couldn't use it but i am
thinking of
what i'm gonna do all right i'll bring
it next week okay even though it's
downstairs
um and i got the sentry mode cam
so try any funny stuff when my tesla is
parked
and you're gonna pay the price you're
gonna be on the summer jam screen
um uh so but i wonder what
the legal ramifications are as long as
you can't identify her i think you're
good
yeah i'll have to pixelate her we'll
we'll have well no i don't know that'll
be done in two
yeah exactly
that's a okay b
uh i joined a vegetable club
because i'm a 77 i'm an old uh
white woman an old caucasian woman
mm-hmm
um i joined in i in fact
i joined two vegetable clubs i joined a
local one
um where it's called la littlegems.com
they go go ahead it's just local farmers
and um and but i'm a little mixed
because i
i believe that all all farmers are
racist
yeah that's the hardest you gotta do the
one the c so do you do the cesfa box or
whatever the [ __ ]
no okay that's the one with all local
farmers
like it's a bunch of local farmers and
they well yeah this is all locals
okay so i'm but i'm assuming they're
still racist i know
so you can do one where you buy from
black farmers only
black farmers only is the name that's
like
um i have a friend that's a black farmer
and she goes to a black farming
convention
what kind of weed does she grow folks
i'm from the 90s where we used to do a
lot of
stereotype jokes that that's over now
but they still come to me
um you're an old one the problem i
joined
l.a little gems was uh uh great great
that's great what did you get
sent peaches uh
plu-outs plutts uh
uh broccoli cauliflower
and then i and strawberries from jerry's
berries or harry's berries or something
um and that i they're really nice
[ __ ] berries
okay like they're they're 15 for a 10
and i was like
and then i saw i was like you know what
what how much did that box cost you
i think i don't know i want to say like
50.
okay and they might have been way less
though you're gonna get that once a
month
well no i'm going to get it once a week
you can get it as much you want that's
too much
i'm already done with here's the problem
i picked it up on wednesday i'm already
done with the fruits
so i gotta this week i'm overdoing the
fruits
under doing under
irregular foods.com i went there
they've been advertising a lot i go on
there improper oregon
it's not irregular it's called like ugly
food or imperfect and perfect
um proper improper
incorrect and here's the great thing
about them
you can't even look at the vegetables
until you put a credit card in
they're so you [ __ ] no it's just
wrong
it's like oh you can't even not choose
no
so what and by the way once you put the
credit card in
and then you go like okay let me look
you're already charged
you're on for a week so when you so you
put the credit card in and then what do
you see
do then you get you have a [ __ ]
shitload of vegetables now is it worth
it is it fine or is it kind of like yeah
i wanted to use it
no i liked i would have used it because
a lot of it's not
uh improper a lot of it's just
uh they they're they grow they have too
much oh okay
so um but it's and then it's a long
story i canceled my membership though
because it's like
because i don't like that they made me
put a credit card and then charge me
and they're like your order's coming
tomorrow i'm like i didn't order
anything i just looked
wow um yeah no it's yeah it was just
wrong and
i i wrote in there i wrote them an email
that was like
or when i was filling out why i left i
was like it
your methods seem more like a
pornography site
oh yeah like paid yeah i really and by
the way not even anymore you just go to
pornhub.com
yeah this episode is brought to you by
pornhub.com
we have a great new sponsor but we got
to give them free ads you know how they
are
how do they want our ads they're like
you two [ __ ] you
um so vegetables and then
i went to the nose doctor we're gonna
get some what i call nose meat
out of this nostril and i got a cat scan
of my
head and when i tell you i have like uh
if you looked at my skull yeah it's a
bird
like the this bump it's
it's it's pointing to his like a [ __ ]
it's a it's just a bird face i got a
bird face
okay so i'm mad at that but i will not
get it repaired because it's too obvious
so what did the what was the cat's scan
about uh how
where the what the cartilage was doing
okay and uh it's not doing anything good
no do you have a deviated i had a
deviated septum that i got
repaired didn't they he didn't take out
enough meat
and uh so now i got to go back but if
your nose collapses
that's a real worry that i know two
people that have had
the middle of their septum collapse from
from cooking
cocaine yeah okay two one of them
it came out in the shower ew
ew yes did he pick it up uh
no he pick it up it doesn't go down the
drain he uh
he let it go down the drain what kind of
drain did he he said
he said i don't need to see that and
kicked it toward the drain
ew i'm gonna write down who it was
because it's so [ __ ] hilarious
i love our new writing system you guys
can
the password is the password is
we cannot service
oh my god that makes sense yeah
um you know what was that one girl that
was on
was it saved by the bell like no maybe
who her nose clap
from from keith walker's here
not like tiffany the amber thiessen but
can you have you ever heard a lot of
bark in your life
it sounds like it's on repeat yeah well
it's i mean this guy's got a perfect
pitch
and then he's just kidding repeat yeah
no it wasn't her was somebody else
that's similar anyways her
note like she has a mug shot and her
nose is just
collapsed and it's so sick she's got the
already lying
that is so sad did he get it can you get
that fixed
he can but he's he's like whatever he's
no he's
he's keeping it up as like a
reminder he's basically neil brenningen
brennan brennan
yeah which i i spoke to a a
friend of mine this week and i realized
that what i'm doing it she was an asian
woman
i'm tiger momming myself you gotta tiger
mom yourself
that's my advice to the kids is tiger
mom once you're an adult you gotta tiger
mom yourself
yeah but eating yeah i'm a thai i'm an
abusive mom
you're uh what is it what was that girl
uh
that was murdered her mom's name was
patty patsy
what is her goddamn name she's a little
girl blonde
and she was murdered and we constantly
keep talking about well her mom
her uh john benett germany i don't know
if she was diagnosed
no i thought patsy was like well she
wants you to win of course you've got to
punish
i mean that once you've when you win a
child beauty pageant you can write your
own ticket for the rest of your life
it's
you've got your whole futures laid out
for you if you
had a child in toddlers interior like a
tiara those like beauty pageants i feel
like you'd
be like [ __ ] it we got to win well that
of course that's why i can't have kids
um but the bigger issue is the fact that
all the this week everybody got mad at
that netflix show cuties or something
which i watched tylers and tiaras has
been on tlc for
[ __ ] 20 years and they act like well
no that's different
okay we're not sexualize them then take
the makeup off
homie i watched cuties because the
director
is this um muslim senegalese woman
and i was like you know what also i
watch a lot of foreign films i'm like
defensive is weird i can let me watch
this and she was like it's not
sexual though this the okay so
the movie is just a coming-of-age film
that's amazing it's kind of juxta that
you're you're juxtaposed between like
this muslim strict muslim
senegalese immigrant life and then these
like bad ass french kids that are like
and they're like they're having they
have booty shorts and they want to do
this dumb dance they're like we gotta
qualify for this contest so this girl
really has to fight between
oh i want to be accepted by these girls
but i'm also from extremely strict
culture so it's interesting
the problem because i was like this is
fine
i thought it was like kids [ __ ] yeah
they did a
they did an x-rated blooper scene like
[Laughter]
oh my god no like the hangover oh go
ahead the problem
that i'm and i'm i'm down with like i
don't need everything to be strict
whatever
if you're telling like an interesting
story
so they're trying to do this dance is
part of this the story and they're
trying to qualify for this [ __ ]
contest
and the dance they're doing is
inappropriate there's a scene where
they're doing it and people are oh my
god
it's so bad covering the kid's eye so
that was the point of it but whoever the
director is or the edit or whatever they
decided
how they showed the dance
was so problematic for me it was like
they were they're clearly young because
like when they zoom in on their butts
their butts are like straight so they
don't have hips
they're not teenagers that are playing
young like me yeah they're
like a bunch of nails they were very
young girls and they were like like
[ __ ] popping
twerking and the camera would just show
them
being inappropriate like you can show
them being inappropriate but you would
zoom in on the like try you know when
the
the zoom in on the the crotch open
spread like it was like
that but they were young girls and they
were like
there was a lot of sexual yeah
legs split and then a zoom in on the
vagina
like uh you could have just skipped the
zoom in
or done it from like was it like a sort
of funny office zoom in where they zoom
in on
like a like a gym like did the butt did
the butt
turn and give it a look and they zoomed
in
it was weird like honestly at the end of
it i was like i actually can't believe a
woman did this
because you could do like over the
shoulder look at the audience being like
oh my god and it can imply it all
without
yeah a zoom in of straight like the
frame is thigh
thigh crotch well okay
my my question it well
i just wrote down that that's like every
80s movie had teenage boys jerking off
yeah but they were they were like 9 10
11.
they're young that's but but a teenage
the kids in american pie are still
underage
right no for sure for sure but i think
there's something when you you know that
they don't they don't have boobs they're
they're butt like they're really young
they're pre-sexual yeah right so they're
prepubescent
so it's a lot of you know her panties
get taken down like it's just kind of
it's kind of how much longer is this
thing going to be up on that place
no okay she literally takes it like one
part of the scene
is she they're like you girls are little
you're young you're not women and then
the girl
goes takes off her pants takes off her
underwear
spreads eagle and takes a photo of her
vagina so obviously you don't see your
vagina but you see
everything else and it's like that's
kind of you like you could have just
implied that
yeah i guess it's like uh it's one of
these things where it said probably a
comment on the sexualization the the
confusion of
coming of age sexualization of young
women etc etc
but if it's a female director
yeah who's also i believe probability is
on
men i'm sorry what do you mean meaning
if if women could handle it right adult
women could handle it
underage any woman could handle it so
the problem is who are you showing this
to
yeah and it's you're showing it to men
and
me we can't take it i will say though
you have to sit through
a whole movie about like a coming of
baby
i'm willing to do it you don't really
have to you can fast forward it's it
seems like she's trying to guys the time
codes are
one hour no time codes do not do
guys there's there's something like you
could tell she wanted to be a little
shocking you know you're a director no
one really knows you you want to make
like
let's do something risque but the story
overall was really good
and they could have done it you could
have had you could have done the sexy
everything without the like
the zoom in vagina butt shots
take those out and even the the scene
where she takes a picture of her busiest
one
it was those those dance shots i was
like i mean there's
this little girl and she's just like
like i was like i don't want to look at
this
like i was not looking sorry no i
didn't no no no i'm not i'm looking at
i'm i'm almost don't realize i never
sleep
i'm just looking at camera angles um
yeah
i don't uh i don't know
i don't i is it a big hit
no but the interesting thing is so that
well they said that naturally
go back subscriptions went down just go
back
so that mignon um
that is the ad so that's it mignon is
what is the
what it was called in french right it
that is the ad
it's uh it's translated as a steak
go ahead so it's just an out of girls
which i think is wrong
i think it was wrong of the french to
name it after steak i mean it really
puts the little girls in a position of
being eaten
go ahead so they were shopping that's
the scene of the movie so that's how it
is
in france and then show just look up
cuties american so it was that for
america
which is the last scene it's like a
three-minute scene
um cuties came out on netflix and
with that picture this more sexual one
only in america
and they were like why are you
advertising these little girls
like cuties what the [ __ ] is this so i
actually think most people netflix said
they're deeply sorry for the poster
i think it was the poster was like why
did you of all the whole thing that's
the
least um that tells you the least about
the movie if i saw the movie the mignons
one is
you also wonder who because netflix does
they'll have like four posters for each
property um and i know because i'm their
property
uh they'll have a they'll have a and
then they'll just see
which one is the most pop like what gets
the most clicks
i find it weird though that the american
one had the more raunchy one because
weird i mean i think they probably just
go
what can we what scenes right
we'll make a good poster because that
looks i think the jonbenet documentary
did well
or i mean they it's yeah it's just like
that explicitly
people love [ __ ] child beauty look go
down that one it's just their faces like
i feel like no one would
the same movie no one would be outraged
at that but also no one would watch that
no one would watch that either
no one but i'm saying that looks like
all of the
the the we're doing all visual things
but it's just a
snapshot of four little girls
and it just looks like hey you like
foreign films
yeah it does how about if they're
children you're right like so you don't
even get to
lust after the juliet banos sure who i
don't keep up with
um yeah or sophie marcel i could go on
um guys the time code again one hour
job um i think most people who are
outraged didn't watch it though
of course nobody watches anything there
was apparently a
spike in cancellations meant by spike
they mean like eight times the normal
amount or
it was either five or eight times uh
which the normal amount of that day
so netflix probably lost um 10 000
people i don't know how many people
cancel
but it's they'll get them back that new
neil brown special
um now let's uh wait i
we haven't even started the podcast and
i still have i have a present
i know that what your love language is
bribes
bribes and vibes do i love presents
i love a good eyes closed reveal they
not
feeling available york times oh my god
i got the t-shirts i got us some show
the people please
oh sir the failing
new york times get it do you get it do
you
get it you can show the middle
great great job oh my god thank you i
don't know how good the fabric is it's
not the best it's not great but i don't
care
yes it's about the it's about it's still
really cute
and you know it lets you know you know i
love you [ __ ] presents
i know and i just know you love presents
so i [ __ ] love presents yeah
really i also got a view into for video
watchers
your vision is so bad
it was it was a foot from you what
that print and you had to lean in no
this is fine
i mean you can blame the font now
i mean a lot because it's present time
but
you might want to go to the doctor i
it's it's in it's deep in the negative
i'll tell you what
i'll tell you that yeah i don't know if
that size is good either but okay
oh i'll just make it a crop top it's
great
sweet oh that's good i like it it's cute
and it's a good color for you yeah it's
good
brown and orange brown and orange orange
looks surprisingly good on me too even
that little orange square on your chest
oh
uh okay so uh do you hear about uh
uh ruth bader ginsburg passed on
chad but rest celebratory in
prudence queen
rest in jairus prudence queen
um all i could think of
is how dumb our system is
for supreme court it's the work that you
have to work
until your last day uh you have to
work until the day before you die uh
in order to kind of keep
mo like a good portion of laws
are going to change now because a lady
died yeah that's so sweet
it's so insane and and
america is so locked into
well i don't know what could we do
gerrymandering but let's be honest
most judges are judges until for life
uh yeah but they don't
have authority over all other
jurisdictions
yeah it's weird but they're also not
some are lifetime appointments a lot
most are not lifetime appointments
most judge ships i mean they like
meaning they can obviously retire
yes yes it's at their discretion i think
this
at some circuit courts are lifetime but
but it's so [ __ ]
dumb that this is our system it's also
weirdly archaic it's just like it's it's
it's medieval
it's like pre-medieval the thing is
things that only can be tried by the
supreme court there's so many cases that
can only be tried by the supreme court
and they can't get to them
yeah well she's not going to get to any
of them um
because she is resting in prudence
queen queen um
the uh so now they're saying there's all
this maneuvering
with uh mitch mcconnell yeah
trying to get the new even though it's a
total contradiction what he said etc
i mean you know [ __ ] lindsey graham
said that
thing yeah he actually said use it and
tells me
do it it's such a bad theater politics
is such a bad thing
yeah it's just like sh okay don't be
homophobic toward lindsey graham
um lady lady g j um
here's what so the republican
republicans
i have no doubt that they're going to
push the nomination through and i have
no doubt i have no
doubt that they're going to nominate it
they're going to nominate those women do
that i don't think they do
i think they're going to put it to the
vote i no one knows sorry they are going
to
put it to the vote i think it i think it
could be one of those things where pence
decides
with the which 50 to 50 and all that
[ __ ] um
to do to do a nomination it goes through
the senate and then
it's that's it oh it's just the senate
why
because it's a dumb system it's just the
senate
no um so
so and now so they're democrats are
saying like
if you do this nancy pelosi was on uh
chris hayes uh not physically but she
was on chris hayes
and it's saying how this is gonna be
this is gonna come back to haunt them if
they push this through
maybe but you know what's
not gonna you know what's gonna come
back to haunt liberals if there's six
[ __ ] conservative justices on the
cons on the
supreme court so it's like a real
checkmate
yeah like it's isn't it funny like it's
like this is about
the founding fathers that's a weird
thing to say but i guess that's their
names
made this system in with
in like with it in mind that it needs to
change it needs to evolve
things need to work with like be a
reflection of what's
what's going on with the public and and
the the major faction but also
what's right and what will be right in
the future you know and
the fact that a lady dies and now
most people a majority of people can be
ruled by some
somebody from oh that assigned
themselves to such old
school [ __ ] is so strange to me yeah
it's not majoritarian role
and so wasn't ted cruz on his list like
i think giuliani was on the list but i
don't think that's his real list that
was like
i'm not even kidding i think judge pirro
was on the list
the one on the tv you want to hear from
something like judge reinhold
shout out to bill maher for not doing
that joke i know
judge reinhold i would take judge judy
judy yeah i actually would take um i
think they're gonna push it through
and i think i i don't know if they're
gonna have the votes
but the thing you were saying about the
founding fathers
is they were also sort of they were
assuming
that people were going to be immoral
right and that these there would be
checks and balances
on on negative impulses right
i don't think that they could have
fathomed
this level of corruption uh in terms of
campaign finance trump and mitch
mcconnell i just don't
i mean they were ruled by a monarchy so
they probably
thought anything's possible but i but
the not the monarchy was just a thing
that happened
they didn't like what do you mean
they knew anything was possible but if
they weren't waiting for the king to
step down the king that was about
about uh right about [ __ ] yeah taxes
and
and colonialism and all that stuff i
don't i mean maybe i'm wrong but
i think the same way they couldn't
figure out
they didn't assume like oh there's going
to be missile missiles
they just didn't fathom gun like guns do
what
right they what you can what do you mean
an automatic weapon like you have a
servant who
like they didn't know [ __ ] i think if
they
i think if they disagreed let's say
there was a way for them to come
because everyone's like in the name of
our friend if they came and disagreed
they'd be like you don't know what the
[ __ ] you're talking like no there's no i
don't think that they i think that they
would i actually thought of them today
well i try to think of the founding
fathers once a day
um and i was uh
and i i just thought they'd be like what
they i think they'd be
it would take so long to get used by
how [ __ ] up things are yeah um
i mean it would take them as people have
made the observation before it would
take them a while to get over slavery as
well
they're like like there's no slavery
where are they jamal
yeah jamal um
don't you mean ricketbus um
okay and the other thing that's making
me laugh is the fact that liberals keep
bringing up
uh you know ruth bader ginsburg on her
deathbed
said please don't replace her until the
next
um the next election they don't care and
i gotta say
nor should they i don't give a [ __ ] if
i'm i don't even i don't care
like that's not legal if kavanaugh was
dying and he was like please
replace me with a conservative and we
could replace him with liver we wouldn't
be like i wouldn't give a [ __ ]
you know he did say and i tweeted that
today like i could be wrong i don't know
i'm as liberal as the next guy but but
uh
but is it just law when you when a
dying wishes are laws now yeah and then
someone actually a comic actually dm me
on twitter to go like hey like
to kind of like argue with me about it
really
it's a law i'm like but why are they
even bringing it up like yeah i bet she
didn't
that's not the way the law is um
i mean they're i just think
it's just so weird that we want
conservative
like conservativism is obviously
changing not necessarily dying but
it's not getting stronger yeah i guess
it's mutating
yeah so why do people want because most
of it's identity politics
most people who identify as republican
are poor
in terms of numbers yeah well they just
play the race and gender [ __ ]
right but i'm like why do you want i
just it's very confusing why
because they like people are pushing for
conservatives
they relate to it they
they like it's who do you think you are
yeah who do you pretend you are
it's that we talk about like it's like a
lack of rock it's all that [ __ ]
and i'm liberal i'm uh benevolent and
i'm
i want the best for people and i'm
generous and
but i mean in some ways i'm generous in
other ways i'm not there's a million
ways you could
show that i vote against my moral
yeah i mean not a ton but there's
abortion is a big one if you
you know as louis said if you believe
that
abortion is killing a baby then yeah i'd
be outside
right too um but whatever whatever
uh are you worried
i'm not worried per se
i just i was bummed i was like when i
saw the news
thing come on my phone i was like i
could maybe cry a little
um but i'm
it's just i don't know i i hope that it
begets a backlash
from p i hope that people realize like
oh oh
because they are going to have a
majority of conservative majority on the
on the bench i think mitch mcconnell
should just be like [ __ ] it
no even if the price is we lose the
senate
this we're gonna have the supreme court
guaranteed lock for 15 to 20 years can i
tell you something that's kind of [ __ ]
up and
i don't want to encourage anybody but
i'm surprised that they're
that people don't shoot supreme court
justices they care so much you can't
really get to them
yeah they you don't like know anything
about that right no
um i'm just saying like if someone's
appointed but
again it's there are people who care yes
but they're yes
but they're not yeah they you can't get
to them people don't really want to kill
people no that's the thing you gotta
remember people think like everyone i
feel also that was like a back in the
day
thing more no yeah well you don't i mean
you could i feel like there's way less
assassinations now
i think the secret service is better
and or there's just for rent there's
just [ __ ] they can do
and if you're john wilkes booth
and you are like i want to kill [ __ ]
lincoln
and it's like don't he's 40
he's 40 john luck's booth and
to me they calculated he's like well all
right so i go to jail
jail at that point's not even that much
worse than outside
right in that time because the whole
thing is jail right
at that point um no running i mean just
garbage i mean just garbage facilities
and and or i'm i'm gonna die soon anyway
just because it's
the 1800s yeah they 40 was like 70.
well i i think i i mean it's not yes i
think they lived long
the thing with life expectancy in the
1800s i found out recently and
before whatever 1930 is
if you childbirth is so dodgy yeah that
it brings the
life expectancy down significantly if
you make it or not
and childhood illness for antibiotics
if you made it past like six then life
expectancy was like
in the late 60s oh so yes
but but because so many kids died i just
take something they're [ __ ] up the
numbers
you brats are [ __ ] up my numbers i
know i was a breech baby so
i figured and back in the day it'd be
like you're gonna die
you're done they'd be like we tried to
like
keith is like [ __ ] this you're not
talking about preach babies to me
but yeah so that makes sense yeah um
so so yeah i i think that you're
i'm always surprised there's not more
assassinations in general
but i think it's well somebody sent uh
ricin
to the white house this week they got
intercepted wow
yeah but that's a crazy person it's like
that's definitely going to the mail room
yeah it's like oh that goes right the
president opens the front door and the
mail
here you go sir you got it chester and
then you [ __ ] wow
right um so so
rbg she was a cool chick
i will say did not like the cultural
appropriation of calling her the
notarius rbj
yeah it's just like well you know people
always got to do although i think a
black woman
on started it on tumblr um
that's a weird thing to know well
i'm a weird guy bianca i you know i'm a
member of two vegetable clubs
and i'm getting my nose fixed and i have
a car
and i've got puke footage and you'll
never get your hands on i need to get on
that [ __ ] footage
um okay so what else happened there was
a
the oscars you see the emmys didn't
watch a frame of it
um didn't watch a frame because i just
don't they don't
i don't they hurt my feelings it's not
i'm never happy
why because you didn't get nominated
just i don't like people slapping each
other on the back
and like ah aren't we great you're great
you're great
you're a little bit better than me just
like
like people millionaires
being excited i just don't you watch
basketball it's millionaires being
excited but they have to do something to
get excited
and they also get angry that's the fun
of it oh so if they were like [ __ ]
yeah yeah yes yes if guys got
people got done when they when they lost
yeah they get it's not humiliating
enough to lose they cut away from you
dude they're keeping them sicko
sometimes i'm a [ __ ] real sick i'm
sick in the head bro
you're like no i just don't it's i don't
see them
they're they're competing basketball's
live competition
whereas the emmys is like a bunch of
[ __ ] i haven't seen
and it's all spectacle yeah and it's all
it is a bunch of [ __ ] i haven't seen
anything like mrs maisel
i heard it's good that's what i say the
whole time never watch
i heard it's good yeah never was good
but it's like yeah and also it's
over it's already over like dave won a
bunch apparently and it's like
it's already like foosh like gone
in terms of it mattering and also i
think there's
i think it's they're still i mean i said
when me and dave presented a couple
years ago i made a joke about like
there's no amount of trophies that could
fill
the hole inside of all of you well oh
yeah that was funny i
i do wonder hmm maybe they just
shouldn't have done it
seems a little desperate no i don't to
do it
what you realize is that well the thing
is you can get raises
based on winning an emmy you get bonuses
[ __ ] like that
i don't i don't sound like a silent emmy
i know i don't know what they're
supposed to do in terms of
these people won like be quiet should
ellen have not gone back to the studio
like i don't
should seth not have gone back i don't
know what is
uh acceptable because it does give
people
some respite from yeah bad news although
my mother turned it off because they got
too political i just got an email right
before we went to recording
sorry theresa want just wishes they
would keep their politics out of it
and maybe they will
okay so the oscars
there's eligib i don't really know the
rules
the new eligibility things but it has to
be it's like the
lead it's the ones that weird me out are
the ones about the
content of the movie right but my
understanding of
the new thing is you cannot win an oscar
unless a wayans brother
is in one of the movies is that true i
don't know the rules
have i i just got here i got here late
guys are we
well one of the worst look-ups you've
ever done you looked up the nominees
[Music]
okay hold on what's it say
[Music]
to achieve standard a the film must meet
one
of the following criteria lead or
significant supporting
actors at least one of the lead actors
or significant supporting actors from an
underrepresented racial or ethnic group
asian hispanic latinx i'm so want to
call it latinx
black african-american indigenous native
american
alaska native middle eastern north
african
native hawaiian or other pacific
islander other underrepresented
race or ethnicity so that's one of the
leads has to be that one of the leads
or this a significant supporting
character
like a supporting character that has to
cry
okay um he has to give he has to impart
advice
okay and then read that one because
generals on some okay i'll read it
because you can't
um you physically can't see it yeah
general ensemble cast
at least 30 of all actors in secondary
and more minor roles
are from at least two of the following
underrepresented groups
women racial or ethnic group
lgbtq plus uh people with cognitive or
physical disorders cognitive
who are deaf well that you know how
they're going to get around that
most actors are cognitively impaired now
have you had dinner with her
she is she is cognizable
um main story the main story theme
this is crazy to me sorry guys it's
centered
on an underrepresented group uh
women racial or ethnic group lgbtq
just here's the secret put a wayans
brother in the movie
and roll the dice just like just wanna
just
for for here's you know what's going to
happen i can already tell you what's
going to happen
that bianca is going to get on a oscar
winner at least
i qualify for two um
the they're gonna end up you're going to
have a movie like
uh stand by me or like just like a white
and it's going to be a black guy doing
the voiceover
there's they're going to find ways
they're going to say no it's a
maine we have the blackout like they'll
they'll have darth vader will count as
uh my
yeah they're gonna be i think it'll be
very loosely enforced
it's like cool you did it like you know
when the security pats you down
yeah but if they don't and then then the
whole
oscar race will be about how they wasn't
righteous it was
the the problem is they kind of have to
do it in a way
here's what here's what i would suggest
white people get your movies made
now because this doesn't kick in for a
couple years
no 20 24 i believe i know
watch the next few years all about like
norwegian
[ __ ] really white it up snowstorms
white people cocaine uh the beach
yeah um [ __ ] cape cod cape cod
get a good cape cod movie a lot of
boston movies
just hurry up uh somebody's
probably thinking that right now like i
gotta get this movie made i know
cause before these rules kick in this is
the [ __ ] up thing and this is
someone who's obviously yeah who thinks
woman
tanks biopic i don't know how to say it
um
i don't love i don't love limiting
the type of art someone wants to make i
think that's [ __ ] strange at the same
time
you don't need the [ __ ] oscars so i
don't i also think
like before the there were other rules
that went the opposite direction they
were unspoken
it's like oh well if you knew if he was
produced by like
the weinsteins or this or that so if
anybody's mad about this of course
i'm like why it has to be about that's
so limiting and weird
but there were always rules they were
just
but the rules were more they were
cocktail party rules meaning yeah
they wanted to you just get cachet
from it's like brad pitt has produced
his company
yeah has produced a lot of good uh
a lot of good [ __ ] and it like they're
they're the rules weren't so it was all
subjective
yeah but it was more like it's a
prestige project and like what do you
mean by prestige
i don't know it comes out in december
and it's in about an important subject
and
and and the funny thing is going to be
the person who flouts it like nah
i wanted to make some white [ __ ] yeah
we're coming out and guess what we're
going to be like
christmas day like um it's christmas day
there will be a white out
so let's say uncut gems comes out yep
and then
kevin garnett would they would go kevin
grant that's the lead
sandwich support they're gonna start
saying wacky [ __ ] like that 100
and make sure he has technically more
lines technically more
there'll be versions the the blacker
version when kevin garnett has more
lines
i think this is not i mean i remember i
took a lot of i did a lot of film
classes in college and one of them was
taught by
this lady who was a film critic
and that's when i realized how [ __ ]
inside back door
shake hand [ __ ] this is like they
have dinners to they literally have
dinners and screenings for voters
yeah it's like getting it's like running
for office
oh yeah and they know before they can
tell
who's going to do well before they
explain to you i'm hearing a lot of
people
are going there explain to people don't
live in l.a that like four-year
considerations i don't want
if they don't live here it's not worth
it uh there's a thing called four-year
consideration which
around christmas time the movies
the movies that come out uh to get
nominated for an oscar have to come out
before new year's
of whatever the they have to come out in
like this year the 2021 oscars all the
movies have to come out before
the end of 2020. so they'll do
minor roll outs in new york and la and
then they'll send
screeners to people in guilds like
myself
and you and so that and and academy
members
so to watch the movies and then after
that
once they list the nominees then the
nomination then
the producers of the nominated movies
the studios will have
literally dinners meet and greets it
becomes like a glad-handing
palm-pressing situation uh
like you're running for office you don't
need to raise money you just need to
raise
awareness and they take out which ads
they take out giant ads
yes and they the funny thing is it
doesn't it's mostly for client relations
it's that's the thing my brother was
watching there was like a movie called
something nine it was about alien sector
nine or yeah something huge movie open
against a movie called the goods
starring jeremy pippen
oh wow they mopped did a really hard
bopped them
[ __ ] district nine district
[ __ ] mopped us
you guys good yeah i mean ten six to one
[ __ ] i don't care um anyways around
town so everybody
outside of la is so geeked out on this
movie yeah but in la
it's such good advertising it was always
they rented all these park benches only
no no aliens sit can sit on this bench
if you see an alien sitting on this
bench please call this number guess who
felt good
seeing those uh park benches having a
movie open against
like [ __ ] park what the [ __ ] are you
it was actually so [ __ ] there was
so many likes it was also very looking
homeless people i'm like they look like
this is insensitive
no but i'm saying in l.a we have the
they waste
so much advertising here like the
stranger things how they had did you see
on sunset
it just the whole thing was it's like
beautiful i remember that
bee movie or some [ __ ] like it was
like uh
looked like a term like a transformer
but it was some bumblebee
yeah the one near the store that's above
pinks yep it
its eyes followed you it like has a
sensor so if you walked under it which
is where we park
it would follow me every time and i'm
like that that's such a waste of
advertising in l.a
right but it's not you know who that's
for it's for michael bay
yeah uh it's for whoever the [ __ ] else
was in bumblebee
uh mark wahlberg i'm assuming seems like
he was must have been in it
i mean like the odds are in his favor
that he was in it
uh bumblebee was act is
yeah i don't that late it's some lady
and some dude okay
yeah so it's for them to
butter them up yeah but it's so
it's so obvious you know like for your
consideration
not if you're a narcissist if you're a
narcissist you're like
that's cool they must have those in
every city i mean well no dummy no
it's for you it's literally for you they
spend so much ads in
like out physical ones yes if you go to
fox the fox lot
they buy billboards all around the lot
yeah because they know the actors are
driving there
no yeah it's just the same thing it's
the same thing
it's the experience that it was to say
like this is the thing we did no
it's shut up why would they buy
billboards
around it's not the ones that are
a half a mile away on pico this is
deeper
than i thought this is so of course they
would
that class i took the lady that taught
it that was a
film critic she was saying she's like
it's all [ __ ] [ __ ] up and this is
past this
particular oscars and she's like notice
how city of god was on it she's like
city god was made three years ago but he
got picked up with buena vista
distribution which qualified it
technically disney
she's like finding nemo was nominated
for best screenplay
finding [ __ ] nemo she's like it's
none of this is
yeah it's all yeah it's like is he
really hurt
yeah uh so it's interesting he's finding
nemo the best screenplay
uh i don't i'm against obviously
casting quota casting and not
that a lot of white people are saying i
love it yeah a lot of white people are
going like you know
republicans are going like a firm no one
wants to be there
to f to fill a quota it's like yeah how
do you know
and b yeah they do people want to be
there
regardless and the other great thing
about humanity is we'll trick ourselves
into thinking we deserve it
you know pray quickly you don't even
some people i wouldn't even care
i'm just like whatever just i got enough
it's all like the white people
because of the because of racism so why
is it bad when i get it because of
anti-racism right
i don't buy that i think that meaning i
don't buy that
as an argument that they don't want to
be there i
i'm sorry i find this a little
silly in that
it's like if you're
take a like chappelle show was about
largely about race
it always seems to there's always
they're always leaving someone out
do you know what i mean you should be
able to we wanted to write about that
or uh if i wanna
mort saul is one of my favorite
comedians ever
um and you'll know why when i tell you
this joke
um he did a joke in the 60s and this
joke's [ __ ] racist
because he's a white guy in the 60s but
it's a [ __ ] great joke
he goes um the naacp came and picketed
me last night because i don't have
enough negroes in my act
which is a which is basically what this
is no you gotta have
it's like i mean that's kind of [ __ ]
up though because then literally he's
like
damn in the 60s no it's [ __ ] up but
it's a
great joke it's a great point about like
what do you legit it's it's a creative i
mean
kirstie alley made the observation it's
like telling picasso what
color to paint with um no i know she's
out of her mind
um but like broken clock twice a day
um what do you when there's a show like
saturday live
and it's one guy it's basically one
guy's show
lauren's show yeah white canadian
point of view is white
yuppie you know it's a white point of
view
and you're
the wind is blowing in a direction that
you don't
not like he's against it but he's like
all right it's the country's still
60 something percent white yeah so
it's all this assumption of
i don't know it just i i feel like you
should be able to
exercise your artistic imperative
like friends didn't have any black no
one time the girl that was like messing
around with george uh
seinfeld had very few black characters
yeah
now the the truth is jerry
has mostly most his top
five or six best friends are black not
all of them but like
four out of six or something um and
so it's clearly they didn't wanna
do jokes about racism yeah
like what's our lane
and then working that lane but this is i
didn't mean to
get into this thing but i read a joke
that they weren't allowed to do
on sidewalk that made me laugh real it's
again kind of [ __ ] up but [ __ ]
hilarious
george at some point had dialogue where
he goes you know what
i've never seen a black person order a
salad oh my god which is just so
[ __ ] hilarious like i can't even
it's just a funny [ __ ] observation
imagine if they just
like seinfeld actually went really edgy
but the same like
you know yeah you know what's funny yeah
but i mean they had the puerto rican day
parade they brought the fly
like they that's not their area of
expertise
is is like racial [ __ ] right
so should they have to
but i feel like you know if if curb can
tackle it
and keep it funny like i feel like it
would have been a good challenge but he
didn't do it
for that reason larry did it because
someone must have he just his wheels
were spinning because of hurricane
katrina and black people going to live
in other
people like people black people going to
houston and go like
residents of new orleans going to other
cities and he probably thought
well it'd be funny if he came and lived
with me that's where that plot started
right um but he always had like i just
mean there was a lot of black people in
curb
compared to yes i don't but i don't know
they weren't all the funny thing
is that's right but the funny thing is
jerry's real
has a lot of black friends in real life
and larry
enjoys the tension the racial tension
but
what i mean is he did something funny
with it even though i don't think larry
i agree
right but it was inspired it wasn't
uh [ __ ] we gotta have they're gonna shut
us down
if i don't if we don't have black plots
i
so there's or native american or
whatever or women plots
oh the women plots there was this person
this person was on stage uh-huh
and he was like yeah people well
maybe the story might give it away but
he was like yeah you know people ask me
like why don't i write roles for
other people why don't i have black
people in my movies like why don't i
write rules for
black people and it's like i don't know
any i just i know jews that's why i
write i write
i write roles for my friends like what
do you want from me
and part of me was like okay whatever
like keep it real at least yeah you know
like don't be like no i do like i'd
rather not that but at the same time
but at the same time it play that
backwards
or play that any other way and it's like
if you weren't represented in a field
that you want to be in it someone's like
no you're people whatever your people
may be
you wouldn't it's not like he's the crux
of the problem obviously you know who
cares if not in history but
there's a there's a there's an attitude
towards it where it's like what i don't
know how to write
well that's the added to write what you
know
well you know it reminds me of when
christian mingle
wouldn't let you search for same-sex
marriages and
their reasoning was same-sex couples and
they got taken to court and the
reasoning was
we don't know how to facilitate a gay
relationship
we're a christian line a man's face
with another man's face the drop down
menu
algorithm so then they got sued and they
had to
allow whatever um by the way there's a
new one now
where they're you can't on one bumble or
one of them you couldn't pick
what races you wanted yeah
six months now you could up until like
six months on one of them
shut up no yeah because i don't know
that's fine i mean you don't have to
date a division for to qualify for that
right but
but it's the it's the right idea
but i mean it's again we're being too
we're being too visual it's
mostly i know we're basically we're
people mostly we're shrugging our
shoulders
don't let these lights fool you bianca
uh this is largely i'm not audio
not disillusioned by the line um
the so i said write what you know
is an adage that we can all agree on yes
and then there's also the thing of
you using your platform
to tell stories
of uh underserved communities yeah
that's the which is the opposite of
right what you know and then there's the
third thing
who were you to write my story that's
the [ __ ] thing
so that's why as a i seem like a racist
cynic
when i talk about this [ __ ] but i'm also
like
i've been a writer i know i don't know
how to
i not like i don't know
do we want a shoddy attempt at telling
like an indigenous person story or a
black person
think about green book i feel like
everybody
a problem i have is seeing like the
black story told you didn't think the
guys who did something about marrying
should do the green book
same same direction i know um i just
think that having
like there's a long history in this
country black peop like black
communities and black people's stories
being told
through like how it affected the white
guy
and that's nothing new but you can but
green but like it
misses the problem it's like that's not
the issue green book is a problem
because
i don't know it's weird it's like yeah i
see the problems with green book but
it's like
well white people really aren't moved in
a large group are not going to be moved
unless they can [ __ ] experience
they can people are racist it's that
it's the take part in the
field stat that i loved this isn't quite
they did a study but give me they did a
study
um
in the 90s
they did uh the highest rated show
amongst black people
martin lowest rated show amongst black
people
seinfeld yeah checks out people like
seeing
people that look like them so that's
just
the way we are i don't think that people
were conditioned to like martin or yeah
any of that
they love they're both they're both very
successful very popular
and very good i have a friend that is a
influencer wow igbo how'd you me how did
you meet him
she's she's actually extremely gorgeous
and she's a brown woman
amazing a queen um and
um rest in peace quinn she's so [ __ ]
influence in peace quinn
[Laughter]
she's so stunning and she doesn't have
that many followers and we have like
some mutual friends and i was asking her
like why i can't believe you're quali
great clothes high-end places center
[ __ ] like i can't believe you don't have
more followers and i'm not trying to say
that to be a [ __ ] and she was like
no
it's because most girls on
the internet who like who partake in
like influencing ig model stuff it's
girls that they want to see themselves
and most of it is white and asian women
so a lot of the asian models have
millions of yeah followers in the white
models and she was like
black models just have less followers
because they want to see those
yes they want to see how they look like
they're 16
black people in the country the [ __ ] are
you gonna like
that's you can't beat math in that case
and in the
the the martin jerry thing is
it is demographic obvious it's like
there's so many there's a lot of white
people and there's
a limit there's less black people so but
then martin was a number one show it
wasn't just from black with black people
no it was a hit show though again
no no again the difference between
seinfeld ratings
seinfeld's a hit show martin did well
like there's seinfeld probably got they
averaged like a 26 and i think martin
averaged like a six seven
um i'm sure someone dear neil you were
dead
you're just talking about ratings so um
so the there are a lot of pitfalls
in this uh
it seems like a simple solve
when you're trying to do quota stuff
for um
production it's just really i think they
would have been way better off
they would have been way better served
with black crews
if that had been the mandate dude they
would never do that because most of the
crews are white from the [ __ ] midwest
and they would just
kill from scenes you want to see or see
me valley yeah you want
the amount of times i've had a weird
incident of a crew member
back when obama was president this one
dude was like you know he's trying to
eliminate christians and like oh like
why of me
of all people are you telling me this is
some weird like bad photocopied thinking
off the internet he's like
he's trying to eliminate christians and
i was like in the makeup chair i'm like
oh
okay like i don't i'm not gonna go waste
my bandwidth on you i'm gonna play like
great get away from me and all the
ladies were like i can't believe you
didn't blow up on him i'm like i'm not
gonna blow up on a crazy prison
but the cruise on productions if you
want to find the whitest
there are white guys in boats and
they're in
unions why guys and unions
unions are scary and they don't want
their daughter dating
you know what they don't want to date in
one of them
well the tanks um
she came in here with little tanks um
it's funny because they make
the like my friends my room my old
roommate um
she's one of my close friends her family
does a lot like he was like a producer
on martin
did jamie fox or whatever uh
i go to their studio out in like north
hollywood
or wherever and um they're making like a
lot of shows like tv wands stuff like
that
so most of the cast is black most
everybody's black and the crew is so
white
and it's so weird you can't i'm like why
isn't the
allowance like the amount i can't find
black crew can't find black
you truly cannot find like it is i've
been making
a concerted effort for years and it's
so hard it's just it's one of those
things of like
in order to get in the union you got to
do it yeah it's it's
it's a 50-year problem you know what's
funny
as a teenager i remember there was like
there's way more psas back in the day i
don't see psas anymore but there's a
piece
they won't give they won't give that
time away they sell ads they're like nah
sorry so there was a psa and it showed
like um
a black kid it was all kids a black kid
playing basketball
like an asian girl like dancing doing
karate like doing something asian
and then a white kid like doing or not
playing violin i'm mexican doing
something like
all they were doing stereotypical stuff
it's like you don't have to just be in
front of the camera and then they look
and like all the camera people turn
around they're the kids
they're like get behind the camera too
and in my head i was like
that seems opposite like get behind the
camera but i'm like
i didn't realize that there was a huge
problem
it was weird though it was like seemed
to like aim and i also heard that one of
the little kid
actors behind the scenes was
masturbating in front of the
the little the other little kids and he
said you want to be in a commercial or
not
okay just tell you what i heard um so
rest in peace oscars
rest in peace white movies buy white
movies hurry up and make
your white movies uh i don't know
urgent i i have mixed feelings because i
think people should be able to
write the thing they're good at yeah
then they don't win a [ __ ] award like
most things don't win the world
but for me yeah i don't yeah that's i
mean you just got to be like you got a
gangster and be like nah
this was the material and we don't get
so good
we don't get to win an oscar but the
other thing is oscars aren't that
it's all talent-related it doesn't it's
not that lucrative it's not like if you
win an oscar then
the movie will make it's marginal yeah
it's just to get you a better deal
next year yes for the person so unless
you're a woman in which case your
career will i'm sorry you've hit your
roof um
okay this is from the man who brought
you the
i don't like aoc during doing makeup
tutorials
comes i don't like kamala wearing
sneakers and tims
it's so stupid i don't like it i don't
think it's i
it's not gonna get us any any uh
any working class no this i agree
it's not gonna get us well what's the
difference
um because she because aoc
already has her job and aoc is already
doing
at least in my opinion a good job so if
she wants to do a [ __ ]
if a beauty person comes i was like game
we need to do this for our young
like whatever if she was vice president
and wore like
cool funky kids clothes i wouldn't give
a [ __ ] but if aoc was campaigning
and like started doing all this beauty
stuff i guess i'd be a little bit like
more like
i feel like this is trying too hard like
i don't like when
someone's trying too hard and this feels
like i'm relatable
please it just makes me it just is like
men
are not gonna go for the i don't know
like she can't
sit there and like look like me with my
tits out i mean
i'm not saying i don't i'd rather her
have her tits out than
wear chucks what if she likes chucks
so put some [ __ ] put them on
you ever see working girl you wear the
running shoes to the job
and then you put them under the shoes
and then you joan cusack works next to
you
and you put on the way in the 80s that
they would do it
you'd you walk your running shoes then
put on heels when you got to work
what i'm saying is i'm not i'm not
saying you're demanding it
no one heals what i want are flats i
want ballerina flats
and i if again one hour 43 minutes into
the steak movie you're gonna get a real
nice surprise
um i don't like that she they switched
it up to tim's and then did a shot and
i'm like
black people aren't dumb like stop with
this it's like not
black people i feel like it's pandering
to be like i don't know i think i'll
never get over the hot sauce
hot sauce the [ __ ] up thing is hillary
does
carry hot sauce she [ __ ] loves hot
that's the sad thing well hillary
that was less that was more weird
everything hillary did that wasn't
she has a better problem hillary has a
better problem because everything she
did was like more robotic so when she
didn't it wasn't like
pandering the black i was like you eat
food no i well the thing i don't you
know what it is it's the
it's the kirby enthusiasm episode i
don't want to see my therapist at the
beach
yeah and that's what this is it's paul
ryan i don't like it when they used to
show him windsurfing
john kerry wins are really yuck
get me out of here get put a [ __ ]
suit on
you also don't like ladies bodies i l i
love one man's body
you by the way you got here late you've
waited
no i know but will got here early
because this studio takes two hours to
set up and
um will works here four hours with
commute
um i'm not even it's actually uh
whatever [ __ ] you
um uh yeah i got my i did my glute
exercises before you got it it was
pretty exciting
thank god i missed it pretty exciting um
how's the glute
quickly let's tick-tock what do we got
on tick-tock
i
it's one of these like also why is the
president involved in laws about apps
it is insane to me what go away
it's just stopping i'd rather he wear
chucks
i will say though the funny thing is
there are like there's a lot of like
entertainment people who are like i'm
doing well on tick tock and it's like
your career is hanging in the balance my
friend oh that they like don't the
tick tock's all i got you can't do this
to me man
uh lori lachlan got to pick a present
like a beautiful white queen yes queen
picking
um what did she pick do we know right
right outside of l.a
right just very close
she'll be out in like half the time
served it's gonna be good for her by the
way
her go on becky i think her
sentence was the humiliation the public
humiliation
[ __ ] that i think plenty of people would
take public humiliation
hey instead of this unfair thing like
just be like or we'll slap your bare
butt
oh i'm right there bare butt lynn
lady g is right there as well that's a
lady g
that's the lady g lady g's a lot
um yeah i i think
i've been thinking recently about how
everyone acts like
getting in a like a twi
you were saying about how death threats
are like the dick pic of the
i think that people underestimate how
harmful social media attacks are
yeah because i think everyone acts like
yeah it's nothing everyone it happens to
either quit social media
reduces like they all something happens
to people where they're like no i'm not
doing that again
like it's significant it's a signifi
i i don't know how to do there was that
john ronson books so you've been
publicly shamed but
where a sheriff who used to make people
wear sandwich boards
yeah said
making people wear sandwich boards when
they have dui's
is more humane than what happens on
twitter like i think that
i don't know how to prove it but so
that's what made me think of the laurie
lachlan thing is
is she's
no one wants to get perp walk no one
wants
it's just a [ __ ] bad look i'm glad
she's going to jail she has she has a
black person
sentence in terms of celebrities she has
a she got a black celebrity
sentence no no no this is a white
celebrity no
what do you mean i mean like a black
person who commits a crime how they get
punished
um worse than a white one on average she
has
in terms of celebrities this is so
detrimental to her
image as a some sort of celebrity so she
does it is bad
it is bad for her world it's not that
you are it's a man i mean she got like
she got kicked off the show every it's
just a nightmare all around for her
with this little tiny bubble she's in
yeah she has a terrible sense but like a
lot of people have done
a lot of stuff he's done [ __ ] up [ __ ]
and we don't talk about it and they just
got off and
it didn't catch fire it didn't do
anything you know um
so in that sense yeah compared to her
life but
you know i don't know i think there's
something
about serving an insane amount of time
that like
you'd look back and like publicly shaped
yes but what i'm saying i think you're
you're pr you're confirming what i said
also which is
that it is her career is over yeah yeah
for sure
like that's a tough one for her world
it's the worst
yeah so that that's what i mean by like
well then she's served it's not time no
i'm happy like go away
you know but at the same time it's the
the punishment is
like before the sentence the punishment
of getting
pilloried publicly and getting bounced
off shows it's like
the thing is i actually don't i think
it's a really
i think it's a really harsh sentence i
don't think it's something
two months i think it's a harsh sentence
it's more that i think
everybody everybody everywhere who has
been
in trouble for trying to get their kids
in a school
somehow like i don't think we should
send them to jail it's not so much that
like
she should get a harsher sentence it's
that other people should get a more
lenient sentence you know
uh because there's i don't think it's uh
i don't think it's
i think it's corrupt it's just a form of
corruption
for sure but and it's it's
she it's a rico law i'm kidding um
i mean what do you do people shouldn't
that's [ __ ] up
it was [ __ ] up it's [ __ ] up in a way
that
that i feel like people rich people have
been doing a long time yeah and she it's
like insider trading where
yeah it's just like that's just you
don't sorry martha
yeah it's [ __ ] live by die by i mean
martha was [ __ ] but
no but she she you can tell when someone
has an insider
tip and as insider traded you can tell
most of them do
most [ __ ] my the the stock market is
so corrupt yeah
it's all the it's all inside and then
there yeah
do you ever watch greed msnbc yeah
oh man there's yeah they're all it's all
it's it's
you look at the stock market going up
since the pandemic you go oh this is
so wrong so immoral and it's a different
game
and it's so funny how we think the stock
market is a reflection of
how the strength and the health of our
economy people are going to think that
anymore
it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] they moved
it from the front of the failing new
york times it used to be on the front
and since the pen they did it for like
the first three weeks and then they were
they just buried it because they were
like this is not
we're doing so good yeah it's like a yes
it's
a fundraiser for rich people yeah that
they're like and we
look at the talkboard 27 000
points take that [ __ ] you're getting
more money than you
an extra layer of money you don't need
um
the kid on cheer was a child molester
it's pretty cool um again
i feel like what was f what here's what
here's my arc
with the kid on cheer um the
the the fact that everyone in l.a was
like i'm obsessed with cheer
and i'm going to have him on he went to
the vanity fair
oscar party and it's like what do you
know about this person
nothing you just think he's sassy and
knitted it's like you don't [ __ ] know
[ __ ] about this guy
and it turns out he was soliciting uh
12 and 13 year olds to send him
yeah if you're a celebrity it's like no
one the guy from cody from
step by step wife peter what
what it's just you don't know people um
he went from step by step to hand to
hand come on give me something
give me some i can't help it i just
bring my brain just what about the
lebron
james asking him to asking him to donate
villanova
it's like it's just these cops are these
cops are lost
they're just lost they're [ __ ] lost
they can't you want to talk about
not being able to take a punch their
days are like
why you i'm calling in sick
and uh i'm going to retire i'll show you
it's just like you're [ __ ] lost
it's like ding-dong to begin with and
you're who's getting walked out of the
courtroom going
just like you won't get away with it
yeah yeah yeah
they're lost they've got rmp cops um
my very close and personal friend
punky johnson is guessed as
one of the new members of snl
wonderful i had no idea i know punky
i whenever i saw her do stand up she was
drunk so i
ignored her shut up this is years ago
but he's drunk
um not tiger dead um
uh and but you said that she does
a lot of characters and i wish i'd known
because i would have recommended her but
she didn't need it no and the nice thing
she's honestly the most
humble person at the store because she
was always like i don't want a favor
i don't want to ask you know adam to get
me pass i'm gonna do on my own when i'm
ready
like never use the fact that she's a
charming
awesome person to get her in anywhere
she was just like i'm on my own timeline
i don't want to owe anybody anything
and just went out for snl um she does
insane characters she doesn't i think
for her tape
most people are like this is you know
joe biden hers was like
this is my impression of a [ __ ] that
wants to go
get like she it was just like she was
like those are the impressions i can do
i can't
do an impression of someone i know so
um and it was funny that so the only
thing i didn't like so i'm very excited
for her
i'm very good and it's like the only
reason why i'm gonna watch us
no offense uh but
there was an article that was like
snl gayest season ever
and i was low-key offended gay a season
have a funniest season how about
something else
gaius is not cr is chris katan back on
the show
folks from the i you know
mango um you know what
gayest season ever it just seems so
like ugh to boil down and marginalize
someone like
you lick [ __ ] sometimes i don't like
every
well talk to the odds it's all the same
thing imagine though if someone was like
black is the
most asian season ever no they would
never do that but gayest season ever
it's just like
i think they would black is here i think
there's a show called blackish maybe
essence could make an article like that
the blackest
is abc today the blackest
yeah the blackest [ __ ] yeah blackish
is
already a show like i don't i buy your
offense
but i'm not paying top dollar for it
i will buy it uh i'm buying it at
ross i told you i went to ross right
why oh yeah you're like they have
furniture and like you're furnishing
so i got nba socks that are like
literally like
you know i'm talking to people here he
was like hey have you been to ross
they have furniture ross says furniture
gang not even a sponsor oh you're so
rich
i it's it's exciting not even a sponsor
what is
uh chris rock has a learning disorder
what
why wouldn't you just dry snitch on your
friends it was in the heat dries
cinnamon on himself
okay we're gonna have him on the show
and we'll talk about it oh my god
really yeah we're gonna do the i have so
many questions
can i ask questions we're gonna play of
course you can
but we're gonna play the game we played
with blake
where i'm gonna cue he has so many
stories
that he doesn't know how funny they are
and how crazy they are
so i'm gonna play true or false okay and
you can
um you will and then he'll he'll tell
the story okay
um all right doc
watch social dilemma obviously nightmare
it's it's social media's atrocious and
it would be the end of us irredeemable
and
it's a frankenstein's monster mark
zuckerberg's frankenstein
and he's acting like the the the monster
that's ravaging
the hillside is like no you know he's
bringing
communities together he brought you
apples he brought you
why the torches um by
smashing your house and strangling your
dog
your your livestock it actually brought
you closer together you just didn't
realize it
um let's do some mail
wait i have to tell you about a movie i
saw which it is a korean film
called the whaling and it is so [ __ ]
scary
and it has a 99 of rotten tomatoes and
it is a
online just uh uh prime amazon prime
the whaling it's such a well-made horror
film
it's so [ __ ] good no jump cut it's
just great anyways
can't wait to remake it with 30 black
people and 20 percent latinx uh hello
[Music]
that's nice okay okay let me open by
saying
that we're not gonna read as much hate
mail anymore
because uh people are trying to extort
us
with things we've already said it's like
we'll say something about we'll say
something about fat people
we'll see yeah yeah i will say it will
very much say it together and use it
into the same microphone a lot of the
time
and then they'll go like you need to
take that and
it's like there's this in this implicit
threat to it
that somehow if you don't apologize i'm
gonna
use i'm gonna cancel i'm gonna stop
listening or i'm gonna
and it's like what you're saying is
we've created some monsters
yeah and by the way first of all we're
not going to feed you anymore we're not
going to feed you any more hate mail
and we're you're not going to blackmail
us with our own
show like we put the [ __ ] out
and if you like it cool if you don't
cool yeah someone's like
you know if you guys blank blank blank
i'm not going to listen anymore
i was like goodbye i'm not responding to
i don't know what you want me to do
there's plenty of reasons why i stopped
watching a show i didn't like that one
character
don't watch it's cool don't watch you
don't like the [ __ ] you're going to
miss our group we don't like the black
lady on friends
goodbye goodbye i know that's when i
stopped watching
when uh what's her name [ __ ] i always
forget her name
wow friends hello
you've got mail there has never been a
better episode of how neil feel than
neil and bianca fall in love it made me
laugh
it was a really good episode neil's
frozen sandwiches and cry bank's dad and
neil getting choked up
i've often wondered about both of your
love languages slash myers-briggs
results
i started to email a question about it
but i thought it made me sound
incredibly boring
i'm gonna take your word for it now i
would regret this and can't prove that i
have
always known neil's love language would
be physical touch
that's weird this it's this [ __ ] made
me laugh always
always she doubled down on always neil
constantly grabs his wrist
and i've always thought it's cute but a
little sad
do it i'm moving my watch
ew that's your touching you're like i'm
here but here's what she thinks
no no but she thinks um neil costly
grabs his wrist and i've always thought
it's cute but a little sad i hope you
find someone that makes you happy
and holds your hand you lose her you
sound like such a lady love you both
uh if anyone would come and just hold my
hand
i it manifests itself i wish someone
would come and rub
my back my scratch my head
you would come and jerk my dick i'm a
lonely baby
both that was all she that's the whole
letter her name was coco
um hey coco that's funny she always knew
do you like physical dish i love it what
about what if
have you dated someone that doesn't like
fidget physical dutch yeah
and are you just like love me well not
the physical dutch here's a
here's a you ever find somebody who's
not
a moist a mouth moisture match
excuse me there's no other way to put it
someone who's not saying mouth moisture
match they're too sloppy or too dry one
or the other yes
uh yeah dry yes
we're on the same team if you're gonna
look if you're gonna french kiss there's
no other word for it
you're going to french
haven't said that make it
wet otherwise yeah like
make it like gross like i want to suck
on your tongue
like just girl like just leave the
lips go the upper lip don't
come on play it don't lick my chin
though please don't look at me
you have to stop with the chin licking
you can lick my chest ew
you have hello hair on your chin you
lick my chin
that's what i'm saying i know what me i
know you mean it
because it's so hairy uh so tongue
lashes
you need a mouth moisture match or else
you're kind of you're kind of [ __ ]
long term yeah it ain't going past two
months it's like it's cat time
that's right now the other the other
side of it
i've been i i've been
on i was too too too wet too moist for
some too moist for mouths we'll just go
like
i know well the thing everyone should
know about me is that i keep a quarter
i used to joke with a girlfriend i keep
a quarter teaspoon of saliva in my mouth
at all
not even a quarter of i shouldn't i
[ __ ] a joke up
a full tablespoon oh it's i have so much
drool in my mouth at all times
you're the type of guy that you cannot
if you're you can't kiss over them
because more goes in if i'm on top yeah
get your water winks ew
yuck because things are about to get
real moist
you're just like i just can't even
really help like it's just what happened
it's like it now i don't know it's not
like i see a lady you got your tongue
no i'm not playing this game with you um
um but so i've gotten i remember
a girl i was dating sent me a
bunch of emojis saying that my kisses
were too wet and it was very funny
that's really funny
was it it was like the tongue out the
side we were just making fun
like we weren't we weren't a mouth
moisture match
um so uh that's a good title and
i think we all know as soon as it came
out goodbye you've got lstnr since the
beginning i'm a 30 year old
quote man and i don't understand myself
i recently ended a 11-month relationship
with the most amazing woman who's ever
had interest in me because i
never allowed myself to totally be
myself around her i guess i just didn't
feel like i wanted to be in the
relationship anymore
we come from extremely different
backgrounds her is great and mine kind
of shitty
and i didn't feel anywhere close to good
enough for her
it's not her fault though she never did
or said anything to make me feel that
way
it's all me so i ended it without really
giving her a good reason because i don't
really have a good reason
to give myself renting it i'm miserable
and i miss her but i don't want her
uh i don't want to tell her i'd like to
try again because
hey i'm afraid i'll feel those feelings
again in a few months and i don't want
to break her heart again and two she
won't
do anal that's uh and then he actually
shits on himself that's my
one poorly timed attempted a joke guy we
got it
um we here guy didn't need guy we need
it
we don't want to see um uh
i'm afraid that something in me is
terrified of anything good and i don't
want
and i don't know what to do also i load
myself for doing this sir
how neal feeling and what blinky
thinkley
thanks what binkley thinkly uh thanks
you guys
uh go because i have a lot of thoughts
on that okay
uh so self-sabotage is a [ __ ]
and don't shake your head this is what
my whole
premise is about hold on there's two
things
one he's given reasons
i feel like i don't know i don't know
why
exactly if he doesn't know why he ended
i mean this is the problem sometimes
people have a lot of weird intimacy
issues
and it does kind of you do kind of do
push pull keep away
too close you know this is not going to
last i don't want to get my hopes up
i don't want it just not getting so
vulnerable so some people
are they don't they have like
psychological reasons for
having an aversion of like diving in
amazing and just
don't know some people don't have a
healthy relationship with
how a relationship can go they just
think it needs to
accelerate and then oh that is that yeah
if you're like we gotta [ __ ]
and then you feel that oh my god i've
dated someone like yeah it was and i
would be like
you're scaring me some stuff in your
house but then
it's just like we can just chill at this
level and then they
push away it's like you wanted this what
the [ __ ] wrong with these codependent
people
well why does that happen um it's the
result like what
you push you want it and then you throw
i don't get that that's
i feel like that's attached that's could
be more attachment style
okay um what are your thoughts my
thoughts on this reading this letter i
had a thought
the um electronic letters people call me
emails like homo electronic
letters um and uh
the my thought was i'm gonna open a
museum of fake feelings
and the first feeling in the exhibit is
going to be
i'm afraid of success i'm afraid of
success no you're an alcoholic
i'm my own worst enemy will be i'm
afraid of love
by my fear intimacy right i don't it's
all [ __ ] fake feelings these are all
what are they underneath for what uh i
think they're just uh
you like anyone who fears i self-sabot
it's
you're just an alcoholic you they never
deal with the problem
they always go i'm this thing that i'm
doing even if they're not alcoholics
they're not all alcoholics they
are they're lying i fear
i don't wanna he just didn't like her
enough
and he didn't wanna be with her but guys
get this thing in their head where
she's a good woman and if i don't wanna
be with her there's something wrong with
me
no the odds of these things matching up
are so tiny yeah
so the likelihood of them of a of you
finding a match is so tiny
so people get into this thing of like
something's wrong with me
i'm going to the museum of fake feelings
i have to deal with
i have to cut the ribbon on uh but the
thing is
i'm afraid of success and i'm i'm my own
worst enemy and i fear intimacy it's
just like
it's all humble it's [ __ ] it's
largely [ __ ] there
in this case it seems like he just
didn't want to
he any when he says i miss her he misses
parts of it but
that's the thing he said i wrote and the
most amazing
he didn't the thing is he never allowed
i never allowed myself to totally be
myself so it's like well there was parts
that weren't gelling
there was parts that there was
compatibility issues so you hid your
part
i but i know like i have a friend that
it's a girl
and she is she does have like there was
some
improper touching as a child mm-hmm and
she does have weird
[ __ ] some steak action
go ahead yeah some filet mignon
some steak okay so
she does have her uncle took her to the
steak house
go ahead okay whoa wow somebody's
calling in
is that the comedy gods going neal no is
this the comedy gun
tell your girl to chill
i can't we can't put adam levine on yeah
we can do it do it do it
hey you don't you don't want to be on a
podcast do you we're doing a podcast
talk to you bye
everybody no you're just it's just audio
it's cool bro it's cool
uh what were you gonna send me thank god
oh your tequila company
no no stop um
[Music]
and now i'm throwing that way off of my
[ __ ] game this is terrible um enjoy
your podcast
i hope you guys do really good i can't
you're gonna get so many hits from this
10 20 second this is gonna be the thing
the nbc is gonna come back and apologize
and then
we made a mistake
i'm sending you something to watch on
your time great
um when you're all alone you're thinking
about oh okay so i shouldn't play it on
the podcast all right great
all right all right bye oh you really
are friends with them i didn't believe
you
i'm joking you didn't think life could
be that good
um i was saying my friend has
she actually does have a lot of
this kind of overwhelming anxiety when
it's going good and i remember she said
something like yeah when it's
good i'm like i don't know i don't know
what to do here
and then doesn't just kind of wants it
to yeah i go away
that sounds like legitimacy it's like
it's like my my
obesity argument it's like there are
people who
really have a glandular issue or can't
fix
but most people use the people with
glandular issues to
for their [ __ ] so you're saying that
there are people with legitimate yeah
if you've been molested like yes there
are real problems but if you're
you're just like there's no smoking gun
yeah you just got i don't know it's like
yeah you don't like her
or him or whatever or or but if you
haven't
been to the steak house you got no
excuses
i'm sorry if so nobody if an elder
didn't take you to a steakhouse
then you can't say that you have an
underlying
so uh no also in the museum of fake
feelings
um what else i i love too much
that's going into the fake feelings um
it's not you it's me
that's yes that's a fake feeling um
this is like that snickers commercial
from the 90s where they were like
um they were uh everyone like went
and got a breakable thing like can i get
it it's not you it's me and then they
yeah
people are just mad i love that
commercial yeah um because it's [ __ ]
because people like
don't [ __ ] me yeah it's just a fake
tell me there's so much self-help
that people go oh i'm going to use that
i'm going to use that as my excuse it's
like [ __ ] none of this
it's not apt it's not apropos to your
thing um there's so many more and i
can't remember
goodbye neil bianca lst and all that
big fan really i recently got out of a
complicated but very serious
relationship of nearly seven years went
to college and dated in post school
dated during and post school for a
couple of years i had i
had hesitated to take the logical next
steps such as moving in together and
thinking about proposing
it wasn't until we spent a few months
apart during covid
that i realized my relationship just
wasn't right for us and upon returning
to the same city
in may i ended the relationship this
guy's a [ __ ] or
i think it's a guy uh ultimately i think
we had been making it
out making it work out of convenience
and co-dependence but when things got a
little
less easy it became evident to me that
the relationship created more stress and
anxiety for me
then a healthy relationship should and i
felt confident and secure in the
decision to end the relationship
okay he meets other people
things happen oh this is a funny
question all right within a couple
months i started meeting other people
but wasn't super interested in a couple
in the couple of people i met so i used
the prior relationship as an out
just got out of a long relationship
that's that's kind of a
that's not a fake feeling no that's fine
you can lie to people uh that's
just a lie that is it useful i'm not
sure if i'm ready for anything serious
around a month ago i met a girl that i
really like a lot
by all indications she feels the same
way think we are both happy with how
things are moving along
and i don't want to rock the boat too
much but part of me feels like i'm
hiding something from
her that the last relationship i was in
lasted seven years
and then it ended less than six weeks
ago my question is at what point is it
appropriate if at all
to tell this girl about my previous
relationship and then he goes on
i don't think you ever tell her no just
i think you keep it a secret no [ __ ]
dad you could have told her
on the phone tell her yeah i was i
didn't go six months ago
you know we're still like i also don't
believe in rebounds
oh 100 they're real i don't i don't one
i don't believe
i don't believe in that i don't believe
that if you date someone
seriously the next person you meet
within a certain window cannot be
serious no i don't think that at all
what i think is that there are people
who
break up from a serious relationship and
they don't
in that serious relationship in the
breakup there is some [ __ ] that they're
not dealing with
or they don't want to address or they
don't have the skills
to really process why they did that why
blah blah blah blah
so instead of it's almost like um like a
like a drug fiend like
that anxiety and that like thing creeps
so they take more drugs
people are addicts not because they love
it but because they don't want to go
through the
detox so people not everybody that jumps
into something quickly right after but
there are a lot of people if you have
underlying issues
you're not detoxing you don't want to
like deal with
the reality of and process what happened
in the last relationship so you just
fill it in
and you're like cool actually i need
thai fan or whatever
and they make you feel good they make
you feel wanted they they fill the hole
and you never go through that detox
because it sucks and you just have to do
monkey bars on to the next that is real
and that is a [ __ ] rebound because
i at a very young age knew that ooh this
doesn't feel good
when it ends you know whether it was me
breaking up or not
spoken like someone who got broken up
with go ahead i have been otherwise it
feels great
uh no it doesn't oh um uh
and i knew like i purposefully if i date
someone seriously
i don't date someone for months on
purpose just
in case i'm like not processing
repeating the
habits and i've never dated down ever
i've never did the same i've always
dated like
tanks go ahead shut up
so i just think i believe in like that
it takes like
i don't know like four to six weeks to
be like ah it sucks like it was really
serious
maybe a few weeks if it wasn't but
ghetto i think it's a good feel better
practice
feel bad to process the i also
gotta say you're not gonna believe this
but i think women are more guilty of
monkey bars than men 100
[ __ ] you look at you what do you mean
of course i mean you want to talk about
[ __ ]
everything yeah we're falling in love no
of course women are
i men love really hard
i think a guy is more susceptible to
uh after a breakup like not want to
process
but maybe not necessarily do it like do
it with well yeah we'll just play video
games or just like compartmentalize and
be like or date a girl be like she's
cool and it just it'll never go
deep or whatever is it a rebound if you
play if you played madden
for three months it's like that guys
will do that guys will compartmentalize
they'll get into their work
they'll just be like i'm this way now
that's what i've learned they don't want
to process but
women don't want to process and they
want to fill
yeah yeah i agree um by the way
speaking of video games i liked the
netflix formula one show so much
i bought the video game of formula one i
don't want to know that about you
i i it's too normal like what why did
you do that
i like that you how much you look up to
me
no that's not it that you don't want to
see me love you sitting
around and playing video games i barely
i mean i it i'll do it for like 20
minutes and be like
stop it you'll be like why are you doing
this
you have 40 books upstairs get upstairs
i'll smack myself i'm reading this
one goodbye we'll get it
yeah um
hey neil hey binky lstnr
missing the e neil you know how they say
all comedians slash funny people are
broken people
or something similar i know you're
buddies with seth meyers my question is
is seth meyers the only funny person
that is legitimately well-adjusted
he's one of my favorite comedian writers
so are you but he seems to have a good
upbringing good family and seems to like
a genu
seems like a genuinely genuine good dude
how
kneeler feeler what bianca thunka
thianka
love y'all uh it's a good question
um would you call him legitimately well
adjusted
yes he is legitimately well adjusted the
only
he's got like a little bit of a temper
ew but his tempers he's like
deadpan white guy temper he's got the
neil brennan tone which is like what
oh that's not what are you talking about
no i don't want that
that's stressful that's like you know
what you do you take your anxiety and
you throw it on someone else and they're
like
oh you know what that makes me why 90
billionth person in human history to do
that in a row
that's what stress is you just go like i
have a feeling
here and it's like i don't want this
well then you shouldn't have done the
thing
that made me give it to you uh he
yeah he's he is well adjusted he's not a
narcissist
and the as greg fitzsimmons says
only the true narcissists succeed in
chivas
um or as i call them great grapefruit
simmons
grapefruit simmons hall of fame nickname
um
and uh he the
seth has he's very
sweet and charming oh he seems like he's
not like
high wattage um
you know cat williams or kevin hart or
dave or
or um who's ellen like where it's just
[ __ ] like god damn it's like
instant charisma he has in some ways
produced himself
into a good career which is like the
lesson i took from him which is like
okay so he was doing on snl
and then he just he became the best
writer there
then he got update and he got update by
writing the best
jokes he wasn't especially good as like
a feature on update but he auditioned
for the thing and um
and then correspondence dinner was like
a big break for him
and the and the reason he produced it
well by getting me
melanie baze um
and a bunch of other guys that are
really good writers to write jokes
with them shoemaker him and like
it's like building blocks yeah of
instead of like i'll just go out and see
what happens
he's like there are guys like dave can
just go out and see what happens
um and seth's not one of them
he can seth can do like he's great and
not
thinking improv and all that stuff but
he's
he's like you he's like prepared yes
he's more charming than i am but
he's you're charming yeah i know it's
backhanded
um it's side door it's you don't like
you don't know
that i'm being charming then you're like
might want to see him again
i don't know what it is i never you know
what i never want to see and play video
games because they're beneath them
legola tanks listen the latinx
i love the video so funny it's it's not
racist but man it feels like
it's man it so but most comedians
if the pandemic has taught us one thing
are
uh damaged people and when you
and people somebody asks like why are
all the it's like because the whole job
is pushing transgression is being
transgressive
and seeing where the line is yeah and
sometimes line step up line
habitual line stepper you um you you
cross it goodbye
you've got mail hi nail bianca that
jessica crude controversy brings to mind
the fact that italian americans of
sicilian heritage have 10
sub-saharan that is black dna they're
moors
um should a sicilian-american like
sebastian be able to self-identify as a
black comic
if not what would be the dna percentage
that would allow someone to identify as
a member of a particular race or
ethnicity
i don't know sir stay tuned for the 2024
oscars when that becomes a
thing they're gonna be like people will
take blood
they're gonna it's going to be
they're gonna find it'll be like tax
regulation yeah
where the offshore we had a black guy do
the voice and we mixed that
into the pip the pitch of the crowd like
that's what's going to happen by the way
sebastian used to do
the black room with the storm would
always do well yeah he did good cause
the
there's a lot of like blacks you can go
like you know blacks and italians
yeah yeah we like uh we're doing bronx
sailboxes yeah yeah yeah
um hey guys lst xyz
all right i don't love it uh
in last episode neil you mentioned that
you had an instinct about crowd work and
that you could
tell what kind of a person that someone
is
i'm sure you have a stronger recognition
of things with the
practice of crowdworks but how can you
measure that
um uh when do you find out if you're
quote right or wrong what are your
thoughts on your own observation
curious on bianca's thoughts as well
having seen so much stand-up banks
how nerly furly and what hottie thotty
don't mind if i do don't mind if i do
um i actually
had thought that i figured out a
ha a dating hack tell me women
always say that men talk too much on
dates they do i think
i talk a lot i think it's binary i think
it's one
yeah somebody talks somebody talks too
much and i think women always say like
men just
he i went on date when they just
wouldn't shut up um
what i found is if you find yourself
talking
a lot on a date start talking about her
just
start making observations it's going
like let me guess
start doing something yeah you're
basically doing crowd work
and you'll if you're right it's magic
yeah if you go you you weren't popul
whatever you weren't popular and kyle
you strike me as the kind of person that
blank and you don't even have to like
neg her like
the game you can actually make
legitimate
things and then if they're like actually
you're dead wrong you'd be like well
great
so that's fellas that's what i'm saying
is make sweeping generalizations about
your date
and that is how you will get
sex do you talk a lot
i don't think i do but then
everyone says i cut you off all the time
so and i what i've started doing is
bringing the spatula on dates
and i find that it's not at first
doesn't work and i have given a lot of
women
uh carpal tunnel um between the spatula
and the masturbation spatula is my
steakhouse and
um yeah i just find that i i just don't
want to be
the vic i don't want to victimize that i
don't i've seen
too many female comics talk about how
dumbly confident men are and i'm like i
don't want to be like that
i don't ask some questions i feel like
you just i do ask questions because i am
genuinely curious
um but i also do the thing where you go
hey yeah and then they tell you it's you
just use it as a
cue you cue them but you get to talk
right you're talking about them so
they're like but the thing is people are
really interested when you say i feel
like
i know it's like a magic trick thing my
magic trick is i
say i'm like you know what i'm a fake
psychic let me tell you
see if i'm right yeah and i guess things
and they're like
yeah that was actually that was kind of
spot on like um
i live on a street and not an avenue how
did you [ __ ] know that
boulevard baby uh so wait what was it
so oh how can what are you right or
wrong
right uh how do you in terms of
instincts based on crowd work
just knowing who someone is you just go
oh
you either either you tell them and then
they go no actually i went to private
school or whatever
or you just realized oh
okay i was wrong about that well i mean
serving especially com
like comedian like working comedy clubs
for as long as i have
you just you know i know what you're
gonna do i know which comics
crowd they bring is gonna do what we
know which comics bring the broke
[ __ ] we know which comics are
bringing like i could go on
so i know the [ __ ] up part is when
you peg someone and you know it and they
exceed your expectations
i mean i can't tell you how low it makes
it when they don't do
what you think they're gonna do well
usually the thing you think they're
gonna do is [ __ ] up
so that's what we're working with and i
know i'm like he's not gonna
tip he's gonna be difficult and when
they are they
they're awful but they leave you a
really big tip it's like
damn yeah but that's so rare
i find that i i find that the
assumptions you make about people
yeah is they're mostly spot on that's
why it feels bad because you're like i
really thought this was gonna go yeah
and then the next time and then you like
take a break from that stereotype for
like
one time and then the next person does
it you're like i'm [ __ ] right
that last guy was a the the best is when
the
comic is not good at crowd work or
they're not i remember i saw it
there's some late night ones that like
are just getting crowd work and it's
like
it's when you see you don't do that much
crowd work but when you do it's
it's very good i like seeing the
headliner dudes do crowd work more
that don't do crowd work i sometimes
it's good and then sometimes
it's not and i don't like yours is good
when you're
bombing in the beginning oh there's
nothing better than that so you're
wasting my opponent
is so [ __ ] funny so it's funny i
don't feel like i
never do uh
crowd work i don't i'm i don't know i'm
not one of those like
the phone rings i'm like let me answer
it hello like
that just happened i would never do that
wasn't me
i barely recognized the guy who did that
that's another from the museum of fake
feelings right i'm a different who is
that
i don't even i don't even i can't relate
to that person at all that was you no
that's
absolutely you same guy same license one
time sebastian
was like hey gaia you want and he said
and the guy was like
like and he was and then he was like
don't talk to me don't like
yeah bring me and you said sebastian did
he's like
oh okay he did this like 100 times i was
like
sebastian's crowd work is funny
but it sometimes it doesn't work no
it doesn't always yeah it's like it's
but he doesn't funny when it doesn't
he sebastian's like me in in in that he
doesn't like when the crowd
is yappy yeah he's like not he'll go
like
guy yeah yeah guy and then he'll try to
shut it down like look it's
jerk off [ __ ] like he gets impatient
and pissy the way i do that's the mark
of a great comedian
yep um you get impatient and busy
goodbye you guys hey knee and
bianca all right
so funny not bad lsc and er i broke my
girlfriend right as i moved to a new
city almost a year ago but ever since
i've been struggling with dating apps
because i feel like i have no game
reasons being i grew up in a heavily
christian environment and feel
shame around sex in general and
the aforementioned girlfriend is the
only girl i've ever been sexual with
and i still feel a little out of the
loop with dating and hookups you've just
set this guy back six months with yikes
and oh god
oh sorry in the background yikes sorry
best of luck pal i do not have problems
getting matches but i mainly just end up
making small talk that turns into
nothing
uh i feel like i'd be the i'd be way
better at this in person but i'm stuck
with apps given the rona
question is there a formula i should be
following i really just
don't know how to initiate most of the
time how
neafy and what bianco thank all okay
just say
hey you want to meet up no
what did what do you know too early what
do you mean you can't open with hey you
want to meet up no oh my god no but he's
saying that he's like
i mainly end up just the amount of times
sometimes i have to do that
i'm just like it's like asking me too
many questions like dude how was your
day
great how's it like after let's say a
week of talking
and then it's still like oh how's how do
you you want to meet up and
like i don't want to keep talking i
think he'd be better off
saying like literally just say hey there
was an
in the new york times the failing new
york times there was a 37
question things to fall in love just ask
her one of them
ask her one they're great questions i
know but you know the problem is there's
a show a few years back called the
pickup artist
it's a reality show i've read the read
the book ew
no used to watching religiously and then
you after that [ __ ] show came out
dudes would be like
okay girls so would you rather a girl or
teeny popped out in the parking lot
there was a fight
um that was always the one uh no it's
but the ones we did
were real you're asking the person a
real question
i know but like honest okay i'm gonna be
real if you if i if we match and you're
like
who's a dream dinner i would you don't
you don't ask
you say there was a thing in the new
york times
okay the failing new york times and then
you say you then you do the question
you for you answer first then i'll
answer
uh do one at a time it's a lot of work i
think it's worth it
maybe because because you are he doesn't
have a problem with
small talk it turns into nothing i just
feel like i'd be way better
at this in person but i'm still but
again that's from the from
the museum of fake feelings oh and man i
can't
i can't get my shield museum of fake
feelings everyone everyone's going
i mean it's going to be a hit museum um
next to the museum of dawn
yeah um the uh
so yeah you have to
get them and the another thing i've
noticed is when a girl if i'm asking
a girl question i feel like this is a
job interview that is a
dead giveaway that we have bad chemistry
oh
cause if it it shouldn't feel like a job
interview
because i'm asking you actual i'm trying
to get to know you
and you're [ __ ] boring oh yeah
ask or don't tell right so you just tell
me about like
you're just sniffing candles and i'm
supposed to [ __ ] make make something
happen
but the difference like one time on a
date with a guy in here women are
sniffing candles 40
of the time go ahead once i went on a
date with a guy and he was like so
you're not a comedian i'm like no i'm
not
like i would never be a comedian he was
like why not it would be good for your
creator
i'm like i just i have so many good
close friends that are very good
comedians and i think it'd be
disrespectful to say
i could do that like if i don't have
that in me
and i've worked around comedy i've been
a fan of comedy for years
you know it's like it's it's like
delusional i don't like that and he was
like
he wouldn't stop he would kept go
everything well that's his bombing he's
just bombing okay
also he wants to be a comedian oh yeah
he's like why
yeah it's like i can already he's like
no he wants to be a comedian
huh by the way i got uh uh a
um dm on instagram
that i wish i erased it so quickly and i
was like [ __ ] i wish i sent it to you
it was from a guy
who i met when we were filming half
baked and he had a movie idea for me
oh my god so it's like dawg i didn't i
just erased it
so quit my body well you didn't even
read it i'm like a cop
did he pick his shoots did he pitch it
to you
yeah gun bang and i [ __ ] erase it
i can't i got an itchy trigger finger uh
yeah i think he tried
i know he was one of those things i
think he'll like it don't you don't know
listen
you pushing two weeks at grandma's and
you can't even listen to
the the [ __ ] bird the bird with the
mask
was a hit it spade wanted it
spade wanted it immediately it's a big
start uh one of the he had the
number one movie of the year he wants in
he wants to he had like a part for
himself
for the uh he's the bird for the
unmasked no
he slowed them goodbye you've got me uh
hello neil bianca rstna i have a
question for neil that's the
that's yeah one of the one of my
favorite shows growing up was all that
oh
and
recently that the show was one of your
earlier writing gigs was the atmos
now i have a movie to pitch you what i'm
kidding uh what was the atmosphere in
the writers room for the show do you
have to change
or dumb down or dumb down
up your writing style uh to make it
kid-friendly
was it different than writing for some
something like us and other daily show
yes uh the environment was
the 90s mid 90s um
when i hear about like so when i heard i
i
when i was yelling about the adidas girl
a couple weeks ago
the [ __ ] they used to do to me they
would throw [ __ ] at me
in the writers room they would call me
the boy
ouch which is [ __ ] funny oh i just
it's all that's
funny no i know it's just i'm 22. yeah
21.
the executive producer for the show one
time said i should have fired you when i
had the chance
which is yes and no like he was joking
but it's like not
you know it's not warm it's like very
like yeah very [ __ ] like
hobbling you with and there was it was
cutthroat and
[Music]
like not very fun um
and uh and so and which it shouldn't
have been because it was my first job
and
yeah showbiz is hard it's hard to write
things
the only thing i would say in terms
of um what it's like
it's the same mechanism of being in a
writer's room which is
everyone's talking about a scene or
whatever
and you have an idea i used to i was new
so i wouldn't pitch it and then somebody
else would pitch the same idea and be
like [ __ ]
you could have pitched that yeah and
that was the thing it taught me like
just pitch
pitches just go throw it out there
what's up what okay but
what about let's say whenever i was like
oh what if he
gets a job at a pretzel shop uh are
people like that's the stupidest [ __ ]
no
it's not yeah i don't know uh maybe they
just go like
so it's it's not like no one ever you ha
it's hard to like shut the room down
like
what right it's like it's because it is
this like hey let's
break it's just it's like just hot
potato okay
um that's cool yeah so it was like it's
a
it wasn't it was a fun it was a good
first experience
but it wasn't i wasn't honored
in any i mean it was like you know
yeah i made a really bad joke
so that when i was and i thought like i
might get fired for that
why and i don't even because i would
i'll tell you what the joke was
uh it fits you know i said this because
it's anti it's anti-fat
oh i know um there was a
head writer was a portly fellow
right and we we we used to eat after
every taping
and we're in the parking lot and he goes
uh how much would you pay me there was
just a bunch of kids there
like a family and he goes how much would
you pay me to uh grab that
little kid and run across the parking
lot and i go and
i literally didn't even think about i go
i'll pay just to see your run
how many people were there i didn't say
it that loud
but as well as things was like god damn
and what did he say
he he ignored it
ooh ignored to a good zinger well
he was like a good singer at his expense
so he was no i know that's why it's like
he had to just be like
whoops um that probably really hurt his
feelings
uh yeah like if you don't if someone
gets you and you're just like
yeah like yep you've got me i'm i would
not be good at running
right i am not running way so
so i wasn't so it was hard for him to
he's doing a podcast right now going
like one of the writers one time
said he said and i and i'll never forget
it goodbye
mail hello n b lsd lmfao
oh my gosh uh
this we got i literally probably got six
positive fat shaming letters
this is just one of them and i kept it
because it was funny okay
lsd lmfao so right there the guy's funny
i'd like to weigh in on the ongoing fat
shaming of the bait so neil doesn't have
to
i had struggled with my weight off and
on throughout most of my life mainly due
to une
healthy eating habits that i inherited
as a child
uh things started to spin out of control
for me when i got an office job in 2012
and then i
topped out topped out's funny around 280
in 2017. i went from 280 pounds in 2017
to 200 pounds by the end of 2018
and now i weigh about 185. do you want
to know how i did it
i stopped eating carbs sugar and dairy
that's it it was [ __ ] easy
just in case you're wondering i'm 35
years old and i'm 6'1
of course there are some people with
biological predispositions
to carrying extra weight i thought i was
one of them but in my opinion it's
mostly a self-control issue
for the overwhelming majority of
overweight people uh to all the people
that took the time to write
in because they felt shamed stop trying
stop typing emails and go on a [ __ ]
walk
you'll feel better in the short term and
it'll be one step closer to taking
control of your life you're not cursed
you're lazy you're not marginalized
you're unhealthy
you're not you don't need to be
destigmatized
you're actually helping to exacerbate
multiple catastrophic worldwide problems
also fat parents who have fat children
should be charged with child abuse
not really but you know what i mean
wishing all you emailers the best while
you cry into your pint of ben and
jerry's
i'll be off having sex with attractive
people and buying 31 inch waist pants
regards signed neil brennan i
was like that sounds like neil hey guy
this kid
this guy gets my tone i just had to put
i didn't
have to put that because there were so
many of them i just thought we'll use
one of them
now i do disagree with them that you can
be marginalized
and unhealthy so that's my only
goodbye you've got hey bianca neil love
the show first time writer i have a
question for neil but firstly i'd like
to thank you for three mikes
helping me finally commit to therapy
well that's nice
i've been at therapy a few times but
never stuck with it now that i've
been in therapy consistently for a
couple years i'm doing a lot better and
really credit comedians like you and
bill hader for speaking so frankly about
issues like anxiety and depression
look don't bring hater into this my
question is about your upbringing i'm
the youngest of 11 kids
this is an interesting letter same
parents no twins and my
parents are catholic and my dad is an
abusive narcissist that might be where
the similarities end
you recently mentioned your mother ran a
rather draconian household
while my parents seem to purposely
create mess in chaos
uh they orchestrated fights by spreading
rumors among their offspring
had no consistent rules the house was
always a complete mess
and they were hoarders it's chrome
it's bro um as for rules my mother
deferred to my father my father would
constantly change
uh how he wanted us to dress what
extracurricular activities he wanted us
to do
what he wanted us to study etc so he was
super
controlling but all but also super
inconsistent
every child wants their parents approval
but this was a moving target
i always felt like i'd rather be in a
strict household because i imagine rules
would make it a little easier to predict
when i was gonna get my ass beat or get
my
stuff smashed um i don't know if that's
sexual or what
i'd like to smash your stuff that i went
into allen thick there for a second i'd
like to smash your stuff
um uh the similarities and differences
between my upbringing and what you've
described got me thinking is an abusive
home with
consistent rules more or less damaging
than a completely chaotic home
sounds like you inherited some of your
mother's obsession with order rules and
planning
but i feel like i ended up obsessed with
cleanliness and structure after escaping
the chaos of my childhood home
i don't know if that's just part of who
i am or a symptom of my upbringing
i'd be interested to hear what both of
you think
uh first of all this is one of those
cases where
it's like where you go you never know
what someone's going through or
something yeah
that's [ __ ] crazy stuff smashing
and
uh i don't think that's wildly
uncommon what having
crazy parents oh no no um this is the
variety she got
and yes and then how it manifests itself
somebody pointed out to me
that they they were like so nobody no
one in your family is an alcoholic like
your dad's an alcoholic but no one in
your family is and i was like
no most of us don't even drink which is
like you're either
doing it or not yeah whatever it is i'm
doing the
thing or you're like what's the opposite
of that i know the consequences of that
action
yes yeah um so you just got to hope you
get
a good like it's luck of the draw and
the thing that i think the the
alcoholism thing
did did she say he's an alcoholic
alcoholism is a big
um yeah the the
abusive narcissist abuse of narcissists
are are inconsistent
any mental illness there's a ton of
inconsistency yeah including alcoholism
and
yeah all right bianca this is why we
why we do the show i'm just listening no
i got you i really like no
i got you look i'm i'm a great i'm great
podcaster and
it's you i wish i could listen to myself
i can only imagine i just was thinking
about inconsistent
i feel like most people i think being
a parent is just trying to mitigate how
much of your [ __ ] you give to your kids
you know and then when you have a
situation like he grew up in i feel like
somewhere yeah she
sorry like they're just not they're not
even thinking about that but for example
i think teresa
probably i feel like all of her rules
were i maybe it's a good faith
interpretation but i felt like they came
from a good place like they wanted you
to be like
organized yeah that's structured like it
was never like
you know it's probably like i want our
kids to be organized
diligent not rely on the world yeah it's
like it's it's so it's
even though they're tiger moms are good
my mom was very sad hearing that episode
she was like just
can't yeah yeah she was very affected
well mothers of the world um
but there are it's valuable i mean i'm
i'm
successful partially due to motivation
or or my rigidness for sure but
what are you that you do have i think
maybe as a result of your childhood
uh careful you [ __ ]
some like into intimacy relationship
issues
i don't know what you're talking about i
mean i don't ma maybe
you know what i mean like i don't know
you don't think it's the result i
i guess i think that i feel like most of
my relationship
issues are human rights issues
meaning that comes from fairness that
comes from
how that [ __ ] weird [ __ ] but but it's
it also comes from a
total lack of fairness it was my
dad was so unfair my dad was just uh
alcoholic so uh
and it's narcissism and then anger and
then
volatility drunk what like so you have
to gauge
as the child or anyone who deals with
them like what are you
right now and how do i get out of that
yeah um
and it's so wrong and unfair to have to
do that and there's no consistency so
i want consistency with women
at [ __ ] it's like dave said he's
never met someone more obsessed with
fairness than me
yeah but but there's a reason why you're
the outlier when it comes to fairness
amongst people for the most part you
know you care about it the most
right and no matter what it is even if
it's right
if you are the outlier outliers
something
it ends up it's just harder to relate
you know i want
out like you always say where i want
fairness and relationships and you're
like you're at
you're it's not no it's not possible
it's not the point you're just setting
yourself up a losing game
you're playing a losing game and you
kind of know not if i break up with them
no but i don't but i do want consistency
of behavior
that's fine but you want it what i would
agree with i don't think i think you
know i can't have it from a woman
no no no first of all don't use me
you're weird [ __ ] about what
i'm saying that like hello steak
steakhouse
no i think you can't have it from people
the amount you can [ __ ]
program yourself to be like i will do
this because
this is if you ask if you said i need
this behavior from you i need it
consistently
and the person said well then i need
this if i'm gonna do this i need this
if it was doable you would say
okay and then you would do it but always
with this [ __ ]
contest always with this like but you
better do yours because i will do mine
yeah
and that i feel like you're just
that part like of your brain excels at
doing that whereas most people at some
point they're going to be inconsistent
on to certain degrees i don't mind
a little i understand a little
inconsistency but when it's
but you just excel at it so much and
people are inconsistent so
you just excel at consistency that
it's just to me it's setting yourself up
i mean like you know let's be real like
scheduling sex now that is not good see
you at 8 45.
future girlfriend that's the best idea
it's so funny to me okay we talked about
that right
yeah but yeah it's great endlessly
goodbye
you've got mayo hi now bianca first-time
emailer long-time listener this guy
doesn't play any of the games
your guy's podcast is so refreshing neil
you're like a funny older brother
bianca your honesty and insight about
the world especially around women and
the issues they face is heavily
appreciated by me and my girlfriend
hey girl she's even said that if a
three-way situation were to pop off
you're a top candidate wow
really high praise considering she's
usually not into that stuff sorry neil
you're welcome to fall well junior if
you'd like
first of all go [ __ ] yourself i'm only
gonna be there
in the corner you know what i'll be
there if we schedule it
and also i'm gonna fall well junior and
then i'm gonna
extort all of you i'm gonna blackmail
all of you with the tape
um not to mention you're both [ __ ]
hilarious thank you
um i have a situation i'd like to hear
your thoughts on my beautiful girlfriend
is a proud strong cool black woman from
los angeles
uh oh is it me i love that white women
are never proud
it's only black women's well white pride
is weak i know you can't be proud
what are you proud of uh what all
everything we've received
women of my dreams uh etc i'm an easy
going funny yet quietly tortured white
polish ex-catholic from
chicago we met on tinder three years ago
and just clicked one of those instances
where
we're a few months in you feel like
you've been going out for years
in a good way everything about a
relationship has been natural and
healthy we are both
uh we both learn lessons from the past
and are open about what we want for
future blah blah blah blah it's great
there's one sticky point though there
always is
a couple of her friends do not like me
because i'm white
they have said openly and aggressively
to mutual friends and it's made its way
back to my girlfriend
it's a couple of her oldest and closest
friends one man and one woman
so there is a history and they seem
aside from their feelings for me
to be really good and well-meaning
friends who have been there for my
girlfriend in the past
i tried to get some more details
thinking it was something i said or did
that might have given the wrong
impression nope i'm told
it purely has to do with my lack of
melanin
normally cut to i'm a soul he starts
putting blackface on
normally i keep my distance and be
polite what else can i do really but
they are heavily involved in their life
socially
so we have a lot of contact with them
they have recently started to go out of
their way to bring up my whiteness
and my privilege understandably given
the industry and justices we've seen
with george floyd jacob blake
brianna taylor uh i'm not uh ignorant to
our country's history and the double
standards and the grossly
unfair in inequities women and pocs
uh have had to face and sadly continue
to faith
this is and by the way there's a fresh
page
oh my god can we my question to you guys
i see a word barbecue
they haven't mentioned you being
long-winded sir there's nothing about
them not like what do you think
only that this motherfucker's talking
about that white house
everybody questions out the [ __ ]
out the group text uh my question to you
guys is does it make sense to reach out
and try to do anything
a majority of uh poc friends tell me
there's nothing i can do just ignore
them and write it out
a few friends suggested sit down and see
if i can get a doubt
start a jam session um my white friends
have told me to accuse them of reverse
racism
ooh drop those white friends number one
now
we need to start on that racism reverse
parent trap
uh maybe there's another option i'm not
seeing uh
luckily no matter what i know you guys
should be
i know things are solid between my
girlfriend and i in the end that's what
counts
um dude he wants to try and he thinks
it's maybe the catholic thing
i don't think
there's nothing you can do you just
gotta eat you gotta take that they don't
like you because they're right it's
do you know how many people who are like
black
latin whatever and the family is like
hey
but they really are like i just liked
when he or she was with black i mean
everyone goes through it yeah i feel
like at least this day and age we can be
a little more open about when it's like
a white guy with a woman of color
well i wonder at least they're one at
least they're being
friends well they're not being up front
she heard second hand but
but then he says that he could feel the
he could feel
it's coming now they started talking
about the
like carnival what are they going to say
they can't it's not leading to
like a ring ceremony where they where
they go like
it's official [ __ ] but it's we
don't have lingering
but i would say you know
god don't he doesn't really have a
choice
you do not sit down you also there are
some people
that will never you and sometimes it's
just
purely racial they just won't i have
i made my peace with the fact that like
black people
some blind people are just never gonna
[ __ ] with me because
yeah some white people are never going
to [ __ ] with you some white people of
course
similar for the opposite thing yeah or
yes or no or they just don't like
whatever yeah
um it is frustrating
because it's not fair but you
there's it's immutable there's [ __ ]
nothing you can do
there's just nothing you can do you just
have to eventually it may
pass all you can hope is that they don't
like you less
it that's the best you can hope for at
one point you'll do something then
they'll come up and say you did your
thing
and that's how you'll know that but just
some people are just like
man that white [ __ ] over there
it's harmless and it is what it is it's
not like
you know you'll be fine but there's not
a good solution to this problem
no there's you cannot confront it you
just
have to it's there's nothing it's like
you're not
it's a you're playing a game and the
referee is not going to call
he you're going to get bad calls and you
just have to be like play on
yeah there's literally nothing you can
do you're you're you're in the away game
yeah only the it's only the other team's
uh fans yep fans what are you gonna do
water
i'm i'm like just skimming skimming
y'all doing black cheers
you know how the black cheers are i'm
just giving his email and all i see is
uh james baldwin obama get out barbecue
i'm like uh maybe your long-winded
emails are probably
hey the word jumbled it uh where am i
gonna fit in the
james baldwin ship um last time i
checked bianca what um
a lot of people say do you guys have to
take this [ __ ]
to which i say we
do not rest
in prudence queen
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
tell me